[Musique]
le saut à skis il y a un siècle
à une époque où volet relève de
l'exploit ces hommes oiseaux apprivoise
l'air
aujourd'hui les auteurs exploite les
lois de l'aérodynamique pour des
performances qui donnent le vertige
le saut à skis combine deux stratégies
contradictoires
envol l'athlète doit flotter sur mer
pour ralentir sa chute
je dois d'abord fendre l'air pour
accélérer sur la pente
le skieur se fait donc le plus petit
possible à mi parcours la piste se
redresse l'apport centrifuge comprime la
plate ses muscles résiste quand la
courbe s'arrête
l'athlète est libre de bondir mais avec
une piste inclinée vers le bas fond saut
ne fait que réduire l'angle de chute
[Musique]
plus coeur foule alors les 100
kilomètres à l'heure à cette vitesse la
pression de l'air est énorme
en un clin d'oeil l'athlète se
transforme en immense voile l'air
devient son allié depuis les débuts du
sport la posture en vol se raffine on
expérimente d'abord avec la position des
bras
[Musique]
mais la révolution viendra des gens un
peu par accident
on découvre qu'en écartant les skis on
atterrit beaucoup plus loin le style en
v s'impose car lille a deux avantages
d'abord avec les skis v l'athlète expose
aussi son corps a l'air ce qui augmente
la surface de contact
il est également plus facile de
s'incliner pour faire un avec lesq
[Musique]
l'ensemble imitent les ailes d'un avion
exploite le même principe la portance
autour de l'athlète
le flot d'air se séparent au dessus
l'écoulement est plus rapide
l'air se dilue ces différences de
pression tire le skieur vers le haut
envol la claque corrige sa posture pour
se maintenir à l'horizontale et à mesure
qu'ils chutent l'air qui le frappe lui
parvient d'en dessous
l'angle que le skieur forme avec l'air
augmente la portance ou si elle peut
atteindre l'équivalent de la moitié du
poids de la clect
une fois l'atterrissage réussi l'air
joue sa dernière carte
car depuis les jeux de sotchi on calcule
sylvain a été favorable ou non il y en a
juste les pointages avant de crier
victoire
la médaille au cou l'athlète est enfin
et j'ai comme l'air
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]